hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Deadpool Easter Egg video
instead of doing a spoiler review I
figured this would be a little bit more
fun so definitely big spoiler warning if
you haven't seen the movie let's start
with the biggest one first we had a talk
post credit scene so he's in the ferris
bueller robe and does the Ferris
Bueller's Day Off speech life moves
pretty fast if you don't stop and look
around every once in a while you'll miss
it I hope you guys took his advice and
pick your trash up after the movie - a
lot of people are using that as proof
the cables going to be in the sequel but
they were saying before the film came
out that if we didn't put cable in the
seat bowl people would assassinate US so
cables showing up in the Deadpool movies
was a foregone conclusion so not as big
a surprise as Ferris Bueller fourth wall
break remember breaking the fourth wall
big Deadpool tradition in the comics
Ferris Bueller also a really big movie
that breaks the fourth wall next big one
Rob Liefeld shout outs he gets a couple
big ones in the movie so there's
actually a bunch of Easter eggs several
Easter eggs in that opening scene the
title sequence where the cars spinning
around in slow motion it's all CG but
you see Rob L on a coffee cup that's Rob
Liefeld the Ryan Reynolds sexiest man
alive poster the Entertainment Weekly
Green Lantern cover that shows up later
in that sequence the Hello Kitty Easter
egg during this sequence is a bit of a
deep cut if you're not on Twitter so the
reference is to the Deadpool Twitter
account which was only following one
account it was following Hello Kitty so
it's like saying Deadpool is obsessed
with Hello Kitty the scene where he
scares the out of the pizza
delivery boy is ripped right out of the
comic books he orders a pizza to a house
then kills the pizza boy now presumably
in the movie he didn't kill the pizza
boy he just scared the out of him
Easter Egg ception we have to go one
level deeper on the pizza box it's
written famous fie jeez that's a
reference to Kevin Feige later in the
bar someone shouts out Liefeld I think
his name also appears on the Deadpool
list above the bar like the list of
names but there's also a Liefeld and two
sways a street anytime you see a name on
a street sign in a comic book movie
there's a good chance it's an easter egg
for somebody that worked on the comic
book at a certain point the bar sister
Margaret's home for wayward girls is
actually an Easter Egg for the Hell
House bar in the comics there are a
litany of Wolverine Origins Easter eggs
there's the Hugh Jackman mask reveal at
the end mask ception mask within a mask
they make a joke about sewing his mouth
shut and it turns out his prized
possession is actually a wham record
before they reveal it they zoom up on a
close-up of an action figure modeled
after his Wolverine Origins character
and they even lift dialogue from the
movie when weasels talking about Wade
Wilson's past in the Special Forces
travel to exotic places to meet new
exciting people and then kill them
that's a line of dialogue right out of
Wolverine Origins there's a scene when
he's still Wade Wilson where he's
reading of all peoples Mario Lopez's
memoir that's actually a reference to
that viral video that they posted when
he went on Mario Lopez's show and
punched him out it was you know just I'm
announcing the movie the salt and pepper
song that was playing on his tape deck
was actually released in 1993 that's the
same year Deadpool debuted in the comics
towards the end of the film before the
big final battle he runs into agent Bob
from the comics oh my god agent Bob
haven't seen you in a long time haven't
seen you since that TGI Fridays and
speaking of which a lot of you guys saw
this in the early trailers it turns out
that that is actually a Helicarrier
they're fighting on presumably the
crashed helicopter in the Comic Con
footage so if you saw the trailer at
Comic Con they took the cameo scene out
when they posted the trailer online he
makes a joke about being bit by a
radioactive shar-pei that's also ripped
right out of the comics
another big spider-man Easter egg
there's a street sign that says Parker
Boulevard there's a whole bunch of x-men
jokes we see some x-men stuff but the
only one that I consider Easter eggs is
when he says McAvoy or Stewart
I'm so confused with all the timelines
they make a joke about the mansion
getting blown up every couple years
because it's shown getting blown up in
the x-men apocalypse trailer when they
take them into the Weapon X program you
actually see this person with spikes
sticking out of their back that might be
marrow from x-force
big deal for the Deadpool character so
it makes sense that they tease some
things out no idea if marrow is going to
be in the movie but that's just an
x-force Easter egg you all know about
the Green Lantern super suit you know
don't make my suit green or animated
that was in the first trailer he makes a
Liam Neeson
taken joke maybe he's just a bad father
they made three of those movies Liam
Neeson starred in a movie called the
Deadpool he references Batman and Robin
so one they either exists in that
universe or two he reads comic books you
could pick your poison and then it's
kind of a deep cut but the first time
way
Vanessa meet each other and they have
that deck contest where they try to see
who had the worst life and they just
ripped back and forth that's a reference
to a really old Monty Python sketch
called the four Yorkshiremen
where they each just try to outdo each
other with more and more terrible things
so I've only seen the movie one so I
probably need to go see it a couple more
times to try and catch a couple more
Easter eggs but if they're any deep cuts
that you guys spotted just write them
below in the comments it's been really
awesome hearing everyone behind the
scenes talk about what it took to get
this movie made this is like a ten year
plus journey and yeah I guess there will
be more r-rated comic book movies but I
don't expect that many more I don't
think the x-men is ever going to be
r-rated if you want to think of the
first deadpool movie as frankenstein I
feel like the second movie has to be
Bride of Frankenstein if they want to
get really meta really silly they would
do the cosmic entity death in some small
way maybe not a big part of the film
because they're going to be doing cable
but just introduce the idea of death
being obsessed with Deadpool next week
I'll be doing plenty more Deadpool
videos we can talk more about the
sequels we can talk about cable anything
you guys want if there any requests that
you guys have for Deadpool stuff just
let me know in the comments below
there's a game of Thrones trailer that's
going to post tomorrow I'll do that
video first then I'll do my Walking Dead
video because Walking Dead's back while
you guys wait for that stuff to post you
can click here for my Deadpool review
and you can click here for my Batman V
Superman trailer video thank you so much
for watching everybody
baby-sized high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you